- [Female] Pull your shoulder
blades back together.
There you go.
- Okay, three more.
- [Female] Okay, good.
- Wade and I have been
friends here at the gym,
I'm his personal trainer.
And he approached me
with a very serious tone,
and he told me that he wants
to do a bodybuilding show.
- [Tina] In the beginning
he didn't have the control
to get on a machine and
just work the body parts
that we were intending to work.
His hands and his feet
need to be stabilized.
You in?
- Yeah.
- All right.
So I got very creative
and I built up apparatus'
that would fit him in order
for him to secure himself
and actually pull with the muscles
that I was wanting him to do.
Up, up, up, up,
instead of it telling you what to do,
you're telling it what to do.
So let's tell it what to do again.
- Okay.
- Up, wow.
- It has improved a lot.
The basic happiness that
comes from feeling strong
and feeling able, instead
of disabled, is a big deal.
- [Tina] Seeing Wade
accomplish his pro status
as a bodybuilder was the
most unbelievable experience.
This was something no one
ever thought could happen.
And it happened, we made this happen.